I always was a score it felt like that
could pass like it was I think he was a
Score first like when you can when you
can get 50 like that and average 28 and
20 I mean 27 for your career I really
think you will score in my opinion yeah
I think that's understanding him by
calling him a past first player in my
opinion you know what I'm saying so uh
but the longevity is inspiring you know
he's set in a bar for what an athlete
wants to be like like nobody that
everybody could do this but like this
this is like the the one dude that's the
greatest that you can get like you've
seen yeah having a clear example of that
now or something you know
um you know especially in our era
basketball if you have somebody that
accomplished something like that is
inspiring to see you and it's going to
set the precedent for basketball players
for a long time